Even if I possess Yuna-san, in the
unlikely event that someone who knows Yuna suddenly appears, will
I be able to behave
properly?
It's the best choice
Okay, let's get possessed with the 10th Are you ready? Good
surgery Are you
okay?
No, I was looking for something else that
I was bitten by.
I just want to protect Yuna I'm
sorry
[music] I'm
aiming for a chance to admire her thighs Casually and
naturally I'll
take a bath before going to bed I'm
sweating from running outside  Hey Jesus If that's the case then I
thought it would be embarrassing to show up to Toka-san, so the two of us
rubbed it together Is it okay?  You can't
enjoy Yuna's futon with this.